today is mexican independence day so all
week we are highlighting hispanic
heritage indeed and there was a big
party in north las vegas last night to
kick off hispanic hispanic heritage
month here was liberty park our ted
florento was there
hispanic heritage month runs from the
middle of september to the middle of
october also in north las vegas this
celebration was taking place over at csn
on cheyenne food live music mariachi
plata that's csn's award-winning program
hector showed them to us a yesterday
now that program's only been around for
three years but it's already having a
huge impact
we just want to be that that place where
students come out here and can perform
stay involved in mariachi and and be
competitive and we can we can
bring that to the to the valley
some of the marquis on the strip also
helping celebrate the month lvcva helped
coordinate a takeover on las vegas
boulevard which included more than a
dozen properties and you can tune in
this weekend on saturday for our
hispanic heritage special we're sharing
stories of southern nevada as it's grown
into the diverse community that we know
and that we love today
our hispanic heritage special airs
saturday 6 30 p.m right here on channel
8.